uh oh somebody named
ultra bullets in there super speedy i
expect
okay 27 minutes
of bullet an hourly bullet arena
wednesday morning i think i'm going to
get the ultra bullet wizard
they may be berserking me they're an
ultra bulleter
no no berserking
we've been here before in the uh earlier
in the stream
pointing out not too concerned about c3
the the bishop deployment
to d3 they're in the tank what's this
about
why was there a pause there
nobody knows
um
it's kind of rare to see that move
i like my knight can you tell
if bishop here there's queen there which
is kind of annoying
all right i like my position
i don't want to take there right away i
might as well
i should i should have captured there i
could have fallen back to
i thought i would have been time to uh
i could have fallen back some mistakes
being made there
dropped a rook
what is going on here i think ultra
ultra bullets having an off game it's
all
got everything under control
okay they're flying
going faster
okay
that's a round one let's see
fanny banny is in a game oh i already
got their their first game in there
170 in this one i just finished
finished the second game the berserker
all right pushkin blr
not our first time playing
let me try this c5 let's try this c5
stop okay
take one use the big squares in the
position d4 d5
let's castle
all right
should i have really done that
um i don't think so
keep pressure here for a second
they they've abandoned any attack
against my king
my queen should be covering everything
my bishop has to be super annoying to
them
they must really want to take that guy
out but it's going to cost you
costian exchange
oh so down in time
oh why didn't i take
ah
oh man one on time sorry for getting
loud
[Laughter]
how did their king weasel around like
that i i should have played rook h1 a
little sooner
i think it would have been mate when the
rook was on what was it
c2 and my bishop was on c3
oh silliness man silliness
check with a4 a6 is bad there's always a
pause right around here
usually a pause for my opponents
noticed because that bishop stuck it's
tough to complete the uh
the queen side there queen side
development
defend e4 find a cozy spot for the
bishop
castle king side and be satisfied you're
up upon
pawn on a4 clamper
might as well uh
activate to fork irani
and get a knight
another piece
with a fork trying to get here
all right they resigned back to
tournament land where we at
we got eight 244 in there now
245.
uh let's see 21 these games
fly by let's take in a different
direction this time
cover h7 just in time in case they form
a battery
go from 8 on h2 careful now
is this even winning for me
uh oh uh oh
yeah because they had knight h2
i was getting another pawn
i think all right if they captured on e3
there
go bishop f4
all right um take
here and then
all right they got d5 they want d5 they
got it
not going for it i could have grabbed
that pawn right then
your queen wasn't defending d5
what's the big difference here these
guys
in the rooks
b5 bishop d3 pivot on this square
go for me back the bishop up
queen d3 or c2
let's go here i'm not threatening mate
starting to take the bishop in the night
i need a flight square why do
why do i not have a flight squaring yet
let's get the flight square in
this bishop should be pretty annoying
oh really
king position let's take here with check
first
the king is having problemos
doing a good job defending though
why'd i do that
all right probably just going to be a
time when
okay no time we got
16 17
just under 18 remaining
it's been a while for these
this bullet arena on stream
fanny benny just finished a game has six
games in already
a couple berserk wins
fanny benny fm
fanny benny
and go right after my throat here
yeah yes you are
i'm just dropping a pawn
more than that why am i playing this so
silly
get a pawn back
bishop there now
okay
trouble i'm in trouble here
where am i
do something on g6
i can't move this i shouldn't move this
guy
i get some mates where are the mates
huh i was speechless
oh man that was that was bad
got the w on time
no it's dropping pawns uncoordinated
very vulnerable
all right in the end
it's what we want w's
how many times i have to try for that
move how many miss clicks can you have
knight a4 or excuse me h5 i could cover
you're gonna play knight there
all right
i want my knight on c4 if i could get
there i'm in
i'm in good shape that's tempo
there may even be a better square oh
there wasn't really a better square
i don't want to see that break
i don't want to see c4 either
an edge on the clock
i gotta challenge that bishop it's too
good
oh no oh don't do it like that
time time time oh that's a rook
come back to defend
we're getting there
okay no time for my opponent
a little less than half remaining 13
13 minutes 341 in there
fang fang for short
try this quick change of the structure i
think uh the correct approach is to play
f3
a bit sooner
uh hang on want to insert this pacman
mode pawn
my rooks are functioning
hungry pawn
do i have enough on this one let's let's
take here first
whoa why didn't i see that that was a
move okay
a lot of exchanges just then
my rook is really active back rankers
i'm ready to get back ranked
check okay let's get this pawn
being sneaky rook takes pawn they're in
a pin they cannot get out of
actually i should be going for mate
don't be sneaky they're being sneaky
there
sneaky apon man
sneaky apon
the one other piece that can move
besides that king
duo is in play e4
play it maybe e5 is nearby
we go for a mate let's let's get this in
right now
all right stop knight f4
um yeah you could kick me around here
um let's go for that
actually
grab a pawn
watch out for bishop a6
should be easily addressed though should
have put the knight in a pin
bishop g5 instead of rookie one second
chance for it
so watch out for batteries
here you take i could take either way
and then take on h6
how do i want to do it i'm going to keep
my bishop around threatening a mate in
two
it's defended
yeah i'm cool with just getting the
queens off
rook is close to trapped
i think it is going to be trapped you
cover these two
oh my mouse slipped there by my opponent
they want to rook a2 all right
eight and change
32 24 23 22
38 387 in there
hourly hourly bullet arena
nicos is in the game here
monitor
we're gonna get a move gotta move let's
try sicilian somebody was asking for a
fishing pole we'll try fishing poles
see if we have any success at least we
have
uh might be close to fishing pole
oh look at that fishing pole
don't forget about the fishing pole h2
strikes again
what's that move about there was queen
takes bishop oh that was a mouse slip
a queen a5 out of a scandy
okay
let's try c4 maybe we could try a
fishing pole from a different angle now
it's not happening trojan
let's let's try a quick h-pawn
run
f5 again no f5
this is a very good structure for white
i'm gonna shoot for c5
get an a5 first
and then c5
castle first safety first
no way to really save that
in the end that uh that dark square
bishop
for for black isn't really
the greatest around
my king should find shelter over here
or we could enter a rook ending or have
a
super active rook huh all right i don't
want to see queen f2
i should be winning stuff i have a one
pawn island
uh let's take this guy i went there next
or here i can do it like this
these pawns should all fall one by one
yeah superior structure
is what helped out there
under six minutes to go 412 in there i
don't think it's going to get much
higher
just some minutes remaining see we get
next
28 28 this guy has fire the guy in
second
keenan here we go
we got a second strike against h2
alright c3 is different no knight c3
all right fishing pole declined b
and normally i go with b5 however
i'm asking for a4 there
um
take there we got some tricks
happening
i want to keep this bishop such a good
guy
they're asking for trouble how a matin 3
threat
i want that knight to move moved
we got this got this trick
knight g3 queen has to block on a7
h7 that control over g1 sets all that
stuff up
killer piece right here
those rook file mates
strizzy the number four guy
i guess they're gearing up for d5 or not
they
juked me
space or not all right
let's get rid of their their tough guy
a dark square bishop keep the tension
they give up control that e5 they give
up their e5 point
very easily collapse
trying to undermine it now with c5 all
right they've given that up
threatening f4 though they could play
for themselves now
they have to play this but i could take
there isn't enough defense
c5 wouldn't rattle my queen position
enough wouldn't kick my queen from the
diagonal successfully
they had f4 though there after i played
bishop to e2 they should have played f4
and i think they're better and just like
that
i should have played uh something to
stop that move
gotta take with the queen
uh let's try this giving up a pawn
no they don't want it could have been
problems
king g2 gonna let me get that in
queen d3 to f3 if they try some sex
clean h3 stuff
um let's go here
queen exchange i do not mind
cover the knight f4
and this should be winning some material
no no no no
there is that as a defense let's try it
this way
could hit this pawn from a different
angle let's fix this pawn
first
and that one
it's improved like this is this really
an improvement
i don't know oh
all right time time time
let's glue that knight in there
making progress here
oh
i thought for a second i was going to
drop my rook i was ready to make a bad
pre-move
that's a wrap for this one turn of
pairings are closed
all right see how it finishes
these spots may change in the end
it just jumped there i don't know if it
changed up top though
okay it has been a while
52 32 30 top three
that's your page one
all right i don't think i'm gonna go on
some spree of doing tournaments i have
to
take it easy
good games uh
i'll have to do it again another time
i see you in the chat there slowpoke81
thank you slowpoke
all right
you